20:19 has been an amazing year and I
just want to start by saying thank you
to everybody if we rewind one year fire
ship IO wasn't even a thing yet around
that time I was worried that rebranding
the channel would end my YouTube career
but I'm very thankful that that hasn't
been the case and I get to continue
doing my dream job in 2020 I'm extremely
grateful for the support and wanted to
take a few minutes to give you an idea
of my plans going into next year but
first we've got a t-shirt to giveaway
Congrats to waltz of kymaro you're the
winner from the JavaScript 2020 video
send me a private message on slack with
your size and shipping details but don't
feel bad if you missed out because at
the end of this video I'll announce a
second t-shirt winner so you have
another chance first things first I'm
taking a much-needed vacation throughout
most of January I'll be traveling to
Australia and New Zealand but the good
news is I'm not just going to disappear
I'll still be around on slack and I have
a bunch of 100 seconds of code videos
already pre produced you may have seen a
couple of these earlier in the week and
the response has been very positive so
far the YouTube algorithm doesn't really
like short videos like this but I do
think they will add a lot of value to
the channel overall because they pack a
ton of information into a very small
package now that being said I have no
plans to change the existing format
after I get back you'll continue to see
plenty of longer format content about
firebase flutter angular and so on
if you're a pro member you can expect to
see new courses in 2020 along with
revisions to existing courses in
addition I plan to add more advanced
modules to individual courses so instead
of a course that you take from start to
finish you take it to a certain point
and then you can branch off to whatever
advanced feature you're interested in
building with Striped payments for
example you would start with a basic
intro into handling payments then you
could branch off to strong customer
authentication or stripe connect or some
other advanced concept this would allow
me to roll out content more quickly in a
modular format and it'll make the
content easier for you to consume
because you won't have to go through
things that you don't care about now a
few months ago I started working on a
project called spelt fire it's just a
simple open source library that
integrates firebase into some small
components but the main reason I built
it in the first place is because I want
to roll out several advanced UI
components for firebase users that can
be dropped into any framework like
imagine a file uploader widget that can
be dropped into your friend
that automatically integrates with your
back-end infrastructure or an email pass
trought education form that integrates
with any design system now that's
obviously a very big project that takes
a lot of work to do right so I don't
want to rush anything out the door the
last thing I want to talk about is the
migration of angular firebase into fire
ship IO
all of the full courses have been
migrated over already but there's still
a lot of individual lessons on angular
firebase that need to be migrated that
process will be 100% complete by January
1st and the angular firebase site will
redirect a fire ship
none of that content is going away it's
just being fully integrated under one
roof and you can access it with the
angular tag on fire ship at any time I
think that's all the updates I have
right now thanks again for all of these
supports and I will see you again in
2020 oh wait I almost forgot we still
have another t-shirt to give away
Congrats Locke Sean Pereira you are the
second t-shirt winner of the video
thanks again everybody I will talk to
you soon